yesterday gave us a bird's-eye view of
how starkly different the president's
priorities are from those of the
Democrats now yesterday the president
headed to Texas to focus on two
important issues first illegal
immigration and second the energy sector
he also had a couple fundraisers but
back in Washington congressional
Democrats worked on their agenda which
consists of basically harassing Attorney
General Bill Barr about the Muller
report and well this there he is the
goofy house Intel committee chair Adam
Schiff taking a selfie like a junior
high school girl at the House Democrats
retreat now look at that in the
background there are two Trump hating
elites from Tinseltown singer John
Legend and his wife model Chrissy Teigen
now Democrats including Speaker Pelosi
they set mesmerised by the couple's take
on politics in America it's laughing
through the pain but it's also important
to balance that and be able to say where
that true pain is Chrissy was ahead of
the curve on making fun of Donald Trump
I really was she knew well before a lot
of America did that he was a joke and a
con man and a clown and I think she was
a appreciate and in making front of him
early long before he ever thought about
running for president a very classy if
not grammatical pre tient appreciate or
prep I think he means prescient but
who's counting now meanwhile 2,000 miles
away near Houston Donald Trump was
hanging out with a different crowd
visiting a union training center for
Operating Engineers the President signed
a pair of executive orders that will cut
red tape for companies seeking to build
oil and gas pipelines with incredible
grit and talent and spirit you lay the
pipes that power our industries you Ray
the beams that build our skyscrapers and
you are the men and women who get up
every day and make this country run and
frankly make this country great now it's
funny isn't it how Democrats are
spending millions on campaign
consultants and these retreat things
they're doing and they're trying to
attract more of the hardhat voters who
are with Trump yesterday but it's not a
new slogan or a slick marketing campaign
that blue-collar voters want what they
want are policies that help business and
put more money in their pockets well
yesterday show that Trump is an
anti-union by the way he's Pro worker
union training opportunities have given
me a chance to better my operating
engineer making more money building
retirement security and having good
health care this opportunity at this
International training center is going
to pay my dividends it has been a great
experience we appreciate what you're
doing
president Trump to grow this industry
thank you
that applause went on for quite a while
now I'll take that hard Hatter Brandon
Cooper and his co-workers over the
Hollywood glitterati any day and I bet
they're a lot more fun but would Nancy I
was reminiscing with Chrissy and John on
the way over when we won the house the
first time they were there engaged on
their way to Italy to be married and
went to Italy to Italy
whether it was an events for us here
there and everywhere or at the
Democratic national conventions or at
the celebration of our victory John
Legend and Chrissy had been there for us
now Trump doesn't have to beg for
applause what Pelosi seemed after big
for applause interesting and I said
nothing says working-class America like
fawning over celebrities turned
self-appointed political pundits mental
health wise it's been really really hard
for me to to deal with this presidency
there's no other way to say it um I
think it's possible to be really angry
all the time I think it's possible to
constantly want to call out all the
transgressions and all the lies now I've
heard the people with anger issues
always seem to blame others for causing
them it's cos honey you can't find any
joy in your life until Trump is out of
office it's kind of sounded like that if
that's true that is truly sad but it's
frankly not our problem back in Texas
the president was speaking with real
Americans who had stories to tell that
were truly sad ranchers who described in
vivid detail the bodies of illegal
immigrants that they had found on their
property just over the past year the
president was so moved and so affected
about the humanitarian problem at the
border and all the pain it causes local
communities that he decided in a
closed-door event to bring the press in
and I said what can I do for you folks
to create more jobs and we start talking
and the first person gets up and said
sir we have many people dying
coming across the border and we find
dead people from Guatemala Honduras
from El Salvador from Mexico all over
you really should cover it right this
has nothing to do with politics this has
nothing to do with campaigning or my
campaign
this is totally unexpected that I'd have
you in here you see we do have an
empathetic president and he's actually
trying to solve a real problem that our
open borders are creating he's genuinely
interested in hearing from Americans who
are dealing with the fallout of our
failed border enforcement every single
day
Pelosi Schiff and the entire open
borders caucus they prefer to pretend
the crisis isn't a crisis hang out at
the Democrat retreat and go to your yoga
sessions in the afternoon well that
leaves more time to hear from the real
experts Donald Trump treats everything
like it's an episode of what's that
movie the village like where there's
this wall and this and these monsters to
keep outside that we shouldn't talk to
or we shouldn't have anything to do with
because we're in this wall brilliant
yeah that's why the president said the
wall should have a big beautiful door
for people to come in Legally do they
not remember that now while the
Democrats cater to the entertainment
elites that's not a big surprise Obama
did it too the president is working for
the Forgotten men and women of America
now he hasn't accomplished everything he
set out to do yet we have some huge
problems bearing down on us still but
this country is better by almost every
measure under his leadership certainly
no reason to be so angry the Democrats a
vision by contrast seems dark and mad
they're infuriated all the time they see
in America where racism and misogyny
reign supreme if there was one word you
would help particularly women use more
frequently but what that one word be
you're very good at this you're very
good at this that's what our young girls
need just the message for those hardhats
in Texas that's what they've been
waiting for all the blue-collar people I
think not the Democrats better find a
good eye doctor from their Russian
obsession to their embrace of open
borders to green lighting and Fanta side
they just keep failing the vision test
for middle America and that's the angle